Alicia Keys also the mom of two boys and
busy as ever she has a new movie new
music and we sat down with the new voice
coach today who has already shaken
things up on the NBC hit but the dynamic
light I mean we between the four of you
we are definitely friends we all bring
out the craziest parts of each other
drop leg drop
yeah the new gig is fun for Alicia on
set and off you and your husband and the
kids you guys you guys get around and
watch it it's actually a really fun
family night and now when I drop my son
off from school day like I saw you on TV
Alicia is known for being all about girl
power and her latest project queen of
cot way is totally in line with her
message it stars David O yellow and
Lupita Nyong'o Alicia provides the music
for the film about this young girl from
Uganda who actually got the opportunity
to learn how to play chess
my favorite part in a movie is when she
wins the award for like the best boy
chess player part of Alicia's power her
fearlessness like when she walked out at
the MTV VMAs last month without a stitch
of makeup on part of the process of
finding their self-confidence is also
finding your honesty with you so you
don't always feel magnificent and
spectacular
did you ever have any of that try
yesterday and how about this looks like
Gwyneth Paltrow is joining being no
makeup movement oh she posted this bare
face selfie to celebrate her 44th
birthday yesterday she looks beautiful
yes she does and no makeup is free it
really would you do it would you wait a
minute don't listen you waited hour wear
makeup don't let me get a sponge
you